we're gonna look at what is a row
reduced form matrix I'm going to show
you a few examples and hopefully that'll
be enough to clear it up and well first
I'll go over the rules and then I'll
show you for two examples so first of
all let me shrink my text there's a few
rules there's four main rules to this so
the first rule of a row reduced matrix
is that all 0 rows appear below nonzero
rows in a 0 row is any row in the matrix
that is all zeros all 0 rows up here
below non 0 rows so basically what that
means is if there are any 0 rows and the
matrix and a row reduced form matrix
they will be at the bottom row reduced
form matrix matrices ok and the second
row or the second rule oh boy what just
happened assumed way in or something
that's weird okay let's get to
straighten back out there we go I'm not
sure why that happened some hockey a hit
apparently the first nonzero element in
a nonzero row his unity or the number
one first first nonzero element in a
nonzero row is unity which is the number
one two more rules
the third rule all elements directly
below
that is in the same column but lower
down on the matrix of the first nonzero
element in a nonzero row our zero Cohen
might sound a little bit confusing but
basically whenever you have this first
non-zero element being unity all the
elements below that need to be zero all
elements below first nonzero are zero so
basically yeah it's whenever the first
nonzero element in a nonzero rows unity
well directly below that all the
elements must be zero and the last rule
for a row reduced form matrix is that
the first nonzero element of any nonzero
row appears in a later column further to
the right and then the first nonzero
element and any preceding rule row well
this one kind of overlaps with three so
it if you're breaking Rule three you're
breaking rule 4 for breaking rule 4
you're breaking rule 3 so I don't know
if this one's really relevant to write
down but it's on this list that I'm
looking at so we'll write it down first
nonzero element of any nonzero row
appears in a a later column and the
first nonzero element and any preceding
row well that is a little wordy but yeah
I don't I honestly don't understand why
they have this fourth rule if they have
the other ones because if you're
breaking this rule then you break in the
third one so
maybe I'm missing something there that
is entirely possible
well no worries
well let's go to a few examples shall we
okay let's say we have matrix it loops
doing my drawing tool drawing tool where
are you okay say we have matrix a which
there we go so how about that matrix a
which is some giant I don't know we'll
say it's 1 1 3 4 6 and we'll have a few
rows here like maybe a 0 0 a 2 5 7 and
so far no matter where we keep going I'd
say this is a hall zeroes cross here but
we've broken one of the rules already
and that is the first non-zero element
and one of the rows is not unity so that
there that breaks Rule two so that there
is not in row reduced form so we can X
that one not or our F alright let's look
at another matrix and determine if it is
so let's say we have matrix B and it
looks like 1 2 3 0 0 0 0 0 0 here's this
in row reduced form and the answer is
yes the only nonzero row is the first
one and it does begin with unity and all
the 0 rows are below it so this one
checks out as row reduced but quick
example here
go to my row that's not a good eraser
tool better eraser tool select and
delete let's say there was a one right
here then in that case it would be an X
because this 0 row is above it at the
zero row or below it and it would work
but since it's not then it breaks one of
the rules and let's see this one it
breaks the first rule 0 rows appear
below nonzero rows alright so let's do
maybe a few more just for good measure
and see if you can get them before I
tell you the answer 1 2 3 4 0 1 2 3 0 1
2 3 is this in row reduced form I'll
give you a second well there's a problem
and it's right here wow that is unity it
does break this row all elements below
the first nonzero or 0
well that doesn't work because all the
elements before the first on 0 so
there's a first nonzero all and below it
need to be 0 and it's not so this would
have to be a 0 for this to be row mate
for this to be or a reduced form so this
one unfortunately doesn't work and let's
do one last example make a new layer of
matrix D and this one is going to be I
don't know let's just say it's all zeros
is this row reduced form and the answer
is well let's check does it break any
rules all 0 rows appear below nonzero
rules well we're not breaking it
there is only 0 rows
first element first nonzero element in
nonzero rows unity well we don't have
any nonzero rows so we can break that
can't break that can't break that
so in all zeroes is row reduced form and
let's just do one more real quick just
just to show you one last example I know
I said last ones last but bear with me
let's do negative 1 or negative 2
negative 3 negative 4 & 5 then let's do
a 0 0 1 negative 3 & a 0 0 1 0 now the
question for you guys I'm not gonna tell
you the answer this one the question for
you guys and to leave in the comments is
e in row reduced form or not is it could
it be let me know in the comments below
that'll be your quiz for today shouldn't
be too difficult to figure out as long
as you take a good look at these rules
thanks for watching I'll see you guys in
the next one I hope you're doing well in
your matrix math and if you're trying to
learn 3d math or matrix or linear
algebra you might do you good to watch
one of these a day I'm gonna be try to
put an out one a day pretty much for a
long time until I've covered nearly
everything so please subscribe and hit
like on the video if it helped you out
and don't forget to hit the bell so you
can see when I come out with new random
videos tutorials pretty new channel it
helps a lot to get any interaction and
any sub I did make a patreon to help get
some funding so consider maybe donating
a little there that would help me out a
ton towards living out my my passion of
helping people in making videos and it
would allow me to spend more time on
these in time editing them so thank you
very much and I'll see you in the next
one